comment quand on vous appeler pour vous
dire que vous allez être ministre parce
que rien à voir avant
c'est un moment très particulier je le
raconte dans un livre justement on a des
petits signaux pour nous faire
comprendre qu'on va peut-être être
rappelé c'est la fameuse phrase et
comment ça se passe au japon qui vous
dit ça alors au début j'ai un appel
d'une dame qui me dit qu'elle est la
chef de cabinet d'édouard chez lipp et
elle me demande si éventuellement je
suis disponible demain à 9h au brûlage
madone ans qu'ils
n'ont en fait c'était pour un entretien
ce que je raconte c'est qu'en fait avant
de rencontrer le premier ministre ou
président ou des super parce qu'on a un
espèce d'entretien de vérification de
bonne conduite séquelles morales etc et
donc on est à matignon et on est dans un
bureau avec une dame est un monsieur qui
nous pose plein de questions sur notre
vie sur scène pour vérifier si en gros
on à la moralité genre ils vous ont
demandé par jean bas par exemple ils
m'ont posé des questions que je vais
trouver enfin je trouve ça très bien
qu'il ya une autorité tuerie ça mais sur
le moment j'ai trouvé les questions un
peu lunaire jour par exemple ils m'ont
demandé si j'étais déjà parti en
vacances chez des gens qui pourraient
comme hystérique du coup ben je leur
suis redevable
moi je réponds oui le dernier j'étais
chez mes beaux-parents à piriac
alimenter leur maison je vous dis que
vous imaginez si posé la même question à
bernard montiel
merci c'est bon
merci c'est par ici la sortie
jamais de
savoir si j'étais parti déjà ces gens
chez un seul chef d'état étranger
controverse et pourrait du coup me faire
chanter après on s'était jamais mais non
mon milieu bien sûr bah oui majorité en
citer je connaissais pas de chef d'état
avant d'être recouverte quand vous êtes
sorti vous êtes dit gg réussi le truc ni
j'ai réussi ni j'ai pas réussi mais j'ai
tenu cinq ans j'ai été renommé dans tous
les gouvernements entre aucamville
encore de sortie de l'entretien atlante
faute de soins parce que c'est comme
maintenant on sait comment ça me
paraissait très étrange et alors après
vous appelle con alors après je veux
voir edouard philippe qui me demandent
si je suis prête à changer de vie et je
comprends pas trop ce qui veut dire par
là et là il vous avez et vous envoie
dans marié au premier regard
et donc ensuite c'est à quelques jours
où on attend et donc ne sais pas ce
qu'il en est et ensuite on a un appel du
président la république c'est le
président lui-même qui vous appelle
ouais tout à fait away qui me dit écoute
je vais te nommer dans mon gouvernement
tout à l'heure alexis a donc alexis
kohler directeur général de l'elysée va
te nommer et donc à tout à l'heure
ouais c'est beau et là qui suis dit que
tu appelles tu es enfant tu appelle tes
amies non j'appelle personne parce que
je suis superstitieux on vraiment non
vraiment donc j'ai juste dit à mes
parents de regarder la télé oui eh ben
moi moi moi aussi j'allais moi je vais
d'ailleurs je prends l'antenne de ses
mines allocution
merci je vais être nommé dans quelques
instants
ministre au sein du gouvernement
ministre de quoi le ministère s ministre
des sports
ou de la ville accueille la culture a
tout de suite
le beau c'est encore un peu dans les
seine et marnais de ses incroyables donc
là après quand vous avez été nommé votre
mari ils étaient contents pas je pense
qu'il a compris sa part était en train
c'est ma femme ministre conseiller ouais
c'est ça parce que lui je lui disais je
fais la campagne si je suis très proche
des manuels macron et en fait on s'était
séparé peu avant pendant un an et où
venait de se remettre ensemble je
raconte tout de m mais important pour
l'histoire donc je me disais que si je
fais la campagne des manuels macro une
visée genre ouais c'est bien mais je
pense qu'il n'avait pas compris et c'est
au moment où j'ai fait l'introduction du
grand meeting du candidat à lyon il m'a
vue sur bfm et s'est dit jean c'est ma
femme sur bfm et là je pense qu'il a
commencé à comprendre qu en fait oui
c'était pas j'exagérais pas et qu
effectivement j'étais dans la campagne
proche et qu'il allait se passer un truc
c'est que c'est incroyable ensuite
on accepte d'être ministre là on se dit
c'est fini quoi le on peut plus lâcher
son téléphone c'est l'avis de la vie
privée cc c'est cuit non c'est quoi la
vie d'une ministre parce que est-ce
qu'on peut aller aquaboulevard le
week-end mais est-ce qu'on peut aller
non mais franchement c'est mort est ce
qu'on fait plus rien ou pas c'est là
qu'ils trouvent je me pose moi est ce
que le soir vous rentrez chez vous vous
faites un osso buco ou bien en
calendar fait ya des gens qui gère votre
agenda votre cabinet ah oui et votre
agenda est tributaire du parlement donc
en fait il ya beaucoup de choses que
j'ai annulé quand j'étais ministre je
disais à des jambes on va se voir ou
déjeuner où je disais à mes filles je
vais vous emmener chez pas à disneyland
est en fait au dernier moment j'ai
annulé parce qu'on m'appelait parce
qu'il y avait une urgence liée au
gouvernement en fait vous arrivez vous
découvrez votre agenda et vous êtes
protégé dont vous êtes suivi partout par
vous officiers de sécurité par exemple
on parlait de mon mari mais une petite
ballade romantique sur la plage c'est
possible mais à un mètre il ya les
officiers de sécurité qui sont là et que
j'adore et j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des
messieurs vraiment géniaux et hyper
sympa compréhensif et c'est une balade
en pédalo et derrière
c'est donc c'est ça et en plus en fait
vous êtes toutes ont suivi quoi oui
c'est vrai complètement
c'est compliqué bien fait que ces
pauvres un tas parce que leur vie leur
appartient plus un jour tu dis dans leur
ville appartient de ses cascades inc
ces maudites la place est maudit
j'ai pu bien public après je me plains
pas il ya des situations bien pires les
gens qui sont en aide soignant aux
urgences en ce moment c'est évidemment
beaucoup plus difficile qui est ministre
et ministre qu'on a quand même des gens
qui vous aide pour votre vie quotidienne
on a beaucoup de pouvoir on peut faire
changer les lois à agir ça surtout qui
est important c'est les ministres ont
pas les gens les plus à plaindre de la
société mais il ya quand même une
réalité qu'on voit pas forcément on
s'imagine que c'est des gens privilégiés
riches qui n'ont aucun problème est en
fait la plupart de mes collègues c'est
des gens qui font engager de mes anciens
collègues qu'ils se sont engagés pour
l'intérêt général et qui traverse aussi
des difficultés dont ils parlent pas
forcément ce n'est pas parce qu'on est
venu ce que nos parents sont plus
malades que font le reste en bonne santé
et qu'on n'a pas de problèmes personnels
du jour au lendemain on se retrouve avec
un avec un garde du corps un chauffeur
c'est un truc mais en plus vous vous
avez été très très vite médiatisé il
faut être révisé vous étiez une des
ministres les plus connus sous les deux
gouvernements pour pour moi ce parce
qu'aller dans les deux ou trois plus
connaître l'autre connaît le nom en tout
cas non mais ça va bien sûr bah oui mais
même là je pense que même attention
aussi je pense que même maintenant il ya
des gens qui pensent que marc lynch
appareils tant qu'engrais mais je reçois
des messages de gens qui me demandent
des trucs
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai que j'avais
un peu un petit ministère un secrétariat
d'état une petite administration un
petit budget et donc si si je veux
gagner des arbitrages et faire avancer
les choses ben en fait il faut que
j'aille la marolle et je dis toujours
que pour une femme prend la parole c'est
un acte politique d'aller dire ce qu'on
a à dire et défendre nos positions alors
il ya un truc est très drôle aussi
j'aimerais qu'on en reparle mais parce
que si on n'a jamais parlé ensemble
série que nous la première fois qu'on
s'est rencontrés c'était à la suite
d'une une polémique 1 sur touche pas à
mon avis et vous m'aviez on dit pas
convoquer même avait convié au ministère
c'est ça c'est vrai que j'étais j'étais
venu trouver logement rappelle alors
est-ce qu'on peut expliquer pourquoi
vous êtes venu à vélo parce que c'est
pas par monde de l'écologie si je me
souviens bien dans quoi je peux me
permettre en fait vous avez demandé de
ne pas faire de photos parce que les
journalistes étaient à bloc moi je
venais d'arriver jeudi un débat est tout
une polémique je vais rappeler 2,3
règles de bon sens et de respect des
droits des femmes et des personnes
monsieur hanouna qui a l'air d'avoir des
enfants qui a l'air d'être un père de
famille responsable donc je vais le dire
voilà il ya des enfants aussi qu'il
regarde il ya de semonce habilité et on
lui dit est ce que c'est possible de ne
pas faire de photos en venant parce que
les journalistes à fond il parle
beaucoup plus du fait pour rencontre
cyril hanouna du fait qu'on a fait voter
une loi par exemple et donc si vous
venez ils vont vouloir vous interviewez
et tout cas ce que vous pouvez rentrer
discrètement en voiture vous ne pourrez
pas les fenêtres et où il a dit on vous
inquiétez pas je voulais pas les
fenêtres
[Applaudissements]
et
du coup ya toutes les images de
journalistes qui ont pu le filmer on en
a jamais parlé mais je suis sûr que
c'est pour ça c'est pas mal voilà annie
match c'était bien ces matches est
forfait c'est vrai que voilà c'est fait
et c'est vrai qu'on s'est pensée par les
joueurs s'est dit peu de choses et après
on a fait plein de plein de choses
ensemble un fini mat et c'est vrai que
voilà marlène on sait on sait on a
beaucoup échangé pendant toute cette
période où vous étiez ministre avait
même rencontré ma mère au bon marché on
dit ou ce soir oui elle a dit oui
vous étiez avec
[Musique]
donc berman fait s'il fait ses courses
voilà footballeur connu un message à
tous les jours mes courses au bon marché
vous allez me sorte son
[Rires]
mari il ya une dame devant moi dans la
file d'attenté qui me fixe et qui me dit
je suis la maman solana et au début j'ai
cru que c'était une femme pascale a
l'air d'avoir mon âge c'est pas du tout
donc je me suis dit c'est quelqu'un qui
se prend pour là
on a discuté on a fait une photo après
choisissent c'est possible que j'ai
croisés
et bastion grèce et elle sait pas si ça
intéresse vraiment et de
psystar voilà non mais depuis ne se
quittent plus c'est vrai que qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ceux qui disent
qu'on n'a pas fait assez sur le sujet de
l'égalité hommes-femmes bah en fait on a
fait beaucoup et je comprends qu'il ya
une impatience parce que c'est un sujet
sur lequel depuis des générations on a
du mal à avancer donc c'est vrai qu'on
n'a jamais on n'a toujours pas fait
assez il faut encore faire beaucoup plus
mais on a fait voter cinq lois en cinq
ans 150 mesures on a mis on a je pense
qu'on a à lever des tabous avec l'aide
de la société civile bien sûr des
associations des femmes elles mêmes mais
on a levé des tableaux sur les violences
conjugales c'est un sujet maintenant
dont on parle on en parlait pas dans les
murs d'aller encore cinq ans quand il y
avait au moment du meurtre d'alexia
d'aval quand je dis c'est un féminicide
l'enchère plein plateau télé qui disent
à la vente un mot c'est n'importe quoi
c'est pas si grave c'est parfois
jusqu'au bout
marlène justement vous ce que c'est vrai
que ça a été à chaque fois que vous
faites une sortie ya plein de gens qui
vous tombe dessus sur les réseaux
partout même à l'assemblée nationale ce
que ça a été dur sadique essuyé toutes
les critiques parce que j'ai
l'impression que ça au contraire ça vous
nourrit en fait ça des moments il ya des
critiques qui sont justifiés et les
critiques justifiées faut les prendre en
se remettant en question ans dans
peut-être c'est vrai que là c'était
justifié voilà il ya des moments
affligeant et je raconte dans le livre
par exemple ce moment où on décide de
faire une émission ici pendant lé giro
john ou jeudi en fait il faut qu'on ait
un trait d'union il faut qu'on écoute
ces personnes qui ont des revendications
est donc assez au moment du grand débat
national et je veux qu'on ici qu'on
puisse montrer aux gens que c'est
possible de prendre part au débat et je
vais au sénat et là je me retrouve au
milieu du sénat et par donc tout seul au
milieu du sénat faut s'imaginer comme
vous êtes tout seul là il ya un immense
hémicycle avec des centaines de
personnes qui ont l'âge d'être vos
parents vos grands parents qui
souhaitent sénateurs des gens installés
dans le paysage politique qui vous eu et
j'ai un moment où je me dis mais c'est
affligeant parce que un c'est jean son
20ème de malveillance incroyable loupé
une jaunisse de la société seafrance
nerfs et 2 je me dise et j'en passe à
côté de quelque chose ils sont en retard
minute mode balle est décédé à droite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après tout rien c'est un chroniqueur qui
va nous quitter sur le
show must go
et donc oui nous voudrions vous
retrouver au milieu oui oui donc c est
je suis usé pas ce qu'on va faire une
émission et une sénatrice me pose la
question en disant est ce que vous
trouvez ça normal d'aller dans
l'émission de cyril hanouna parce que
c'est bien la place du ministre est allé
à l'époque je suis critiqué us parce que
je viens ici et depuis on va pas se
mentir il ya quand même des dizaines de
ministres et de sénateurs et députés qui
tapent à la porte pourtant être que moi
aussi je peux venir le chercher là quand
je dis vous allez faire l'actualité du
débat politique pendant la
présidentielle pareil n'importe quoi
nous na c'est du show c'est pas de la
politique qui frappe à des débats
présidentiels quelle est l'émission de
débat présidentiel qui a eu le plus de
retentissement c'est ici c'est face à
papa donc je suis navré de constater que
j'ai eu raison trop tôt mais vous avez
des photos que vous soyez de directrice
des programmes
chez tout le monde l'ancien ministre
je voudrais qu'on respecte bernard
montiel parce que pour ma génération
c'est quand même patrick de sous le
soleil du sud
[Applaudissements]
c'est ma vie tu as très bien ce soir ou
jamais de vous dire que patrick ne
me mathieu quand vous venez s'il te ment
pas des gilet jaune à ce moment là
personne n'en parle vous piquer un peu
la vedette au gouvernement c'est là que
moi je vous découvrez beaucoup de
français aussi est-ce que du coup vous
demandez là l'autorisation au premier
ministre au président vous venez comme
ça comment ça se passe vous devenez la
star à ce moment là c'est le moment vous
dire que j'ai une méthode pour avancer
parce que je vais pas attendre toutes
les validations en gros je me dis je
suis pas venu au gouvernement pour faire
comme tout le monde c'était pour faire
comme tout le monde c'est pas la peine
de venir je reste chez moi donc je suis
venu là pour essayer de changer les
choses et moi je n'oublie jamais que je
suis une nana qui a grandi dans la cité
sur le périphérique et qui est là voilà
par la force des choses et tu travailles
mecar devoir vis-à-vis de ces personnes
aussi donc en fait ma méthode c'est sauf
contre ordre c'est à dire que j'envoie
des messages demande pas l'autorisation
j'espère que vous m'autorisez à aller
faire une émission j'ai sauf contre
ordre pour info demain je serai chez
cyril hanouna si j'ai pas trop y croire
je viens avec vous
vous aurez un message
moi je vais répondre à tous le président
est ce que le président le premier
ministre à l'époque vous avez regardé
dans cette émission je sais que le
président chez il n'en a pas parlé
directement sur le moment mais je sais
qu'il a regardé en tout cas au moins des
extraits et le premier ministre à
l'époque je sais qu'il a regardé je sais
que son équipe a regardé en fait le
lendemain ce qui est marrant c'est que
j'ai plein de messages de félicitations
de gens qui m'avaient trash et la veille
de gens qui m'avaient dit en gros qui
avait dit elle va pas s'en sortir ça va
être une catastrophe
le lendemain il voit les audiences ils
voient que ça fait un record d'audience
et voit qu'en fait on a fait une vraie
mission citoyenne avec des propositions
n'étaient d'accord ou pas d'accord mais
voilà avec un vrai débat est donc
immense venant quand même c'est bien et
des gens qui m'ont dit j'avais jamais
regardé hanouna havre est en fait
finalement fait 20
des gens qui m'ont dit finalement il
bosse
beaucoup et un millier
c'est une banon et on peut plus rigoler
oui elle investit la isla bonita ce
qui est fort avec avec marlène et avec
son livre c'est qu'on veut que vous êtes
hors système est hors cadre et on sent
bien dans le lit votre liberté ton votre
indépendance voilà vous êtes ailleurs on
peut pas on peut pas vous étiqueté mais
ça je trouve que c'est très fort mais
vous parlez vous avez subit aussi une
sorte de violence vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure et aussi des raids numérique et
ça ça m'a beaucoup plu parce que vous
êtes vraiment atteler à ça aussi pendant
pendant le quinquennat et je voulais
parce que souvent on en parle ici par
rapport aux jeunes justement les
insultes les injures les menaces vous
avez une application je crois vous en
parler et ça je te refais une appli qui
s'appelle bo d'ivoire c'est pas d'action
à la pâte code promo n'y a rien
non c'est une application est faite qui
bloquent toutes les insultes et tous les
propos insultants voilà vous permet
d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux
sereinement donc il ya sans doute des
gens qui sont en train d'y aller bien
insulté marlène schiappa pour faire un
jeu n'est pas vu c'est d'appliquer à
tout bloquer ceci dit j'avais quand même
une équipe un cabinet qui a déposé
plainte il ya beaucoup de personne j'ai
jamais communiquer dessus il ya
plusieurs personnes qui ont été
condamnées pour menaces de mort pour
cyber harcèlement etc pendant le
quinquennat et il faut dire que c'est
surtout les femmes et je pense pas que
les femmes politiques j'imagine que les
femmes public c'est aussi à la même
chose c'est quand même plus les femmes
qui sont menacés sur les réseaux sociaux
le retour de patrick
j'ai tout fait j'ai avalé de travers
c'est pas grave je suis désolé pardon
plus qu'à manger un petit robot vous
avez raté un hommage à sous le soleil
ouais c'est vrai c'est chez patrick de
sous le soleil et nous a dit je veux
bien comment j'aimerais qu'on respecte
dernière michel patrick de sous le
soleil dionne patrick teen star il ya
justement marlène une fois qu'on est
plus ministre comment ça se passe on
fait ces petits cartons on prend la
sentence est irrévocable
son flambeau comment ça se passe parce
que c'est incroyable du jour au
lendemain mais donc vous partez de votre
ministère là on vous ramène chez vous
quand même au bout du bout du pont über
alors en fait moi j'avais vécu le
précédent remaniement au cours duquel on
m'a donné genre 24 heures pour partir
donc fermé carton déménager allaient
emménager place beauvau donc rentrer
dans un environnement très sécurisé et
puis faire tous les cartons etc et
c'était un peu soudain rapide et un peu
dur même s'il faut toujours relativiser
comme je trouvais tout à l'heure il ya
des situations et le chevalement de
l'impur difficile dans la vie mais c'est
jamais agréable de vous sortir voilà et
surtout de l'annoncer aux enfants de
laon va déménager ou changer d'école
tout ça est donc là j'avais anticipé
donc mes cartons il fait effet depuis
plusieurs mois puisque je savais que le
quinquennat se terminait donc j'étais
préparé préparé à ça mais c'est vrai que
quand vous terminez en fait vous avez
être m'appelle le bd fait le bureau des
cabinets je raconte tout ça s'appelle
aussi son bureau des cabinets voilà
c'est donc il vient et en fait c'est ils
viennent faire respecter la démocratie
et donc ils viennent d'asie à venir ce
que maintenant il faut partir d'hier en
gros tu poses ta plaque et ont flingué
voilà et maintenant tu tu t'en vas tu
n'es prix ministre mais c'est le jeu de
la démocratie c'est normal et il
installe les nouveaux ministres en leur
disant ben voilà c'est bon j'ai collé à
bdc en fin de saison nous sommes en jeu
mais ce qui est important c'est
important que tu sois là
marlène vous êtes heureuse la
passe comme si on vous rappelle dans
quelques années pour un au ministère
vous allez y aller ou pas du tout c'est
dans quelques années j'en sais il faut
jamais dire fontaine je ne boirai pas
ton dit bataille
j'avais pas non plus
non mais c'est vrai donc c'est passé
c'était quand même un beau souvenir
c'est un beau souvenir c'était un
bonheur ça ne
dirais pas qu'elle qui avec l ministre
si on l'a rappelé est elle voudrait
qu'elle ministère on s'en fout on verra
ça plus tard je perds intéressant non
monsieur du coup est ce que fait prix
bas des sports c'est non mais marlène
c'est vrai que mes angoisses et la
campagne aussi etc emmanuel macron et
après de se dire qu'on n'est pas au
gouvernement c'était quoi c'était un
truc conseiller je fais la campagne et
puis après je fais ma vie oui
honnêtement si on était parlé sur mon
blog et par là c'est que ce n'est pas
une posture c'est vrai alors c'est vrai
on si on n'était pas allé quoi même
longtemps bon mois avant elle m'avait
dit je vais et je vais arrêter ouais il
y joue harry tessier non mais si oui ou
non mais souvent tout ça en ayant
beaucoup de respect pour ce que j'ai
fait je soutiens toujours évidemment
présent la république je resterai en
soutien voilà très fort de son [ __ ] est
toujours des contacts avec eux oui
j'étais avec brigitte avant-hier après
qu moins souvent que berlin
je ne suis pas là
alors des joueurs c'est vrai que j'ai un
texto de briques qui me dit ah ça me
fait plaisir bernard est encore vivant
là c'est brigitte à ces de la santé de
bernard montiel il est là et bien là et
pour longtemps vous inquiétez pas non
monsieur vous avez toujours aidé oui au
fait que j'ai c'est une femme qui est
formidable extrêmement empathique très
érudite et adorable alors justement la
question qu'on se pose à ce qu avec
brigitte macron avec d'autres personnes
vous avez parlé de votre avenir qu est
ce que vous allez faire maintenant n'est
plus ministre parce qu'il ya eu
tellement de rumeurs autour de vous et
c'est vrai qu'on vous voit faire
tellement de choses déjà vous avez vous
tourné vers
l'associatif aussi les voulais faire
depuis longtemps c'est très sympa à vous
d'en parler parce que je sais que vous
le faites pas ce que vous savez que ça
me tient à coeur dont j'apprécie
beaucoup et effectivement oui mon
principal projet sculpteur de la sorte
donc là j'étais à new york la semaine
dernière j'étais à l'onu pour présenter
mon projet que la place des femmes dans
la société ça reste ma pause je
présidais dix ans une association avant
jeudi elle est pas arrivé à égalité
hommes-femmes voilà comme ça c'est
vraiment ça a été c'est ce que vous
faisiez avant sa vie vous allez refaire
maintenant je suis en train de monter
une structure avec une équipe qui a pour
but d'améliorer l'égalité femmes-hommes
en entreprise et puis dans la société de
façon générale ça c'est le gros projet
sur lequel j'ai travaillé avec l'onu en
partenariat notamment mais aussi avec
des expertes voilà d'accord et pour le
reste on a vous avez envie dire quoi
bah moi j'aime les médias vous le savez
je pense que ce n'est pas un se pose si
je viens
donc non j'aimerais et c'est une manière
de porter les combats si j'ai pu
apporter ses combats pour y était femme
c'est parce que les médias ont eu la
gentillesse de m'inviter vous avez là eu
la gentillesse de m'inviter à chaque
fois que j'avais quelque chose à
partager à défendre donc oui je pense
que le que ce soit la télévision la
radio la presse écrite c'est des bonnes
ce sont des bonnes manières de passer
des messages et de continuer à défendre
la place des femmes il faut que ça ait
un sens je vais pas faire une émission
pour faire une émission je ne suis pas
une animatrice de télévision c'est un
métier en soi c'est pas mon métier
voilà donc j'aimerais lui dire ça peut
le devenir et ont attribué de cette
manière
vous avez des questions posées mode oui
est ce que vous aimeriez être produite
par cyril hanouna si vous animer une
émission oui
non mais moi je mets là elle laquelle a
pris alors je vais vous dire honnêtement
quelques unes des choses qui me
caractérise et je pense que les gens ont
peut dire la vérité que marlène on s'est
vus il ya longtemps ça fait ça fait des
années que je lui dise comme ça je dis
la vérité de fait des années mais je
savais qu'elle est vrai toujours que la
lettre au gouvernement pour même ovale
lors de son premier ministère après je
savais qu'elle allait certainement aller
ailleurs voilà qu'elle ait continué la
vie politique je l'avais dis je pour moi
tu es tu as un talent et je pense que tu
devrais de tournée vers les médias après
et je vais toujours d'y insérer voilà je
voulais toujours d après jeudi après que
je travaillerai avec qui tu voudras bien
sûr si tu veux travailler avec moi voilà
je te laisserais ma carte voilà
mais c'est vrai mais
voilà non mais je pense que moi je suis
quelqu'un de loyal et en fait c'est vrai
qu'on a commencé ans et cyril hanouna le
premier qui m'a qui m'a suggéré de
réfléchir à ce sujet et puis surtout
c'est pas parce qu'il est là et si vous
êtes là tous autour de la table c'est
que vous le pensez aussi mais c'est
quelqu'un qui a un en ce sens de l'air
du temps qu'il ya un producteur qui sait
tout de suite qui va marcher ou pas
marché comment doit s'adresser à
l'audience et c'est important pour lui
de respecter le public et ça je pense
que c'est quelque chose qu'on partage
pour moi aussi et je pense pour vous
puisque vous êtes là c'est quelque chose
d'important de respecter des gens qui
vont regarder et voilà et d'essayer de
trouver le bon dosage et la ligne de
crête en trop ce qui va vraiment marché
mais ce qui va aussi défendre défendre
une cause dont un
tuyau des articles ont annoncé une
éventuelle arrivée sur ces 8 et donc le
fait que vous pourriez rejoindre touche
pas à mon poste en tant que chroniqueuse
aussi est ce que vous seriez prête à le
faire je n'ai appris dans la presse les
gens c'est super bravo pour ces huit
mois les ministres étaient
donc non enfin c'est pas de contrat avec
ses 8 g pas de mât pas de projet avec
avec ses 8 ce n'est pas ça ce n'est pas
ça le projet
justement tu n'étais pas très clair mais
voulait faire quoi c'est quoi le projet
d'accord on discute pour voir justement
pour trouver le point information
jeunesse à quoi je suis pas j'ai dirigé
une agence de production de contenus
dans le passé mais c'était des contenus
sur le web le format n'est pas le même
le monde de la télé j'espère que
productrice télé donc moi j'ai des
projets ensuite joué à cyril et il a la
gentillesse de vous conseiller de me
dire ça c'est plutôt un truc radio ça
c'est plutôt un truc télé ça c'est
plutôt web voilà et de m'aider en fait à
affiner affiner le projet veut dire
comme ça oui voilà donc on travaille en
ce moment voilà il renverra en tout cas
voilà je pense que j'espère entre 4
marley ne viendra vite sur une antenne
voilà pour voir un truc qu'on a on a on
en train de travailler on entre en
travaillant ensemble sur un conte avait
dans la tête d'ailleurs depuis très
l'autre paie assez longtemps et voir ce
que ça peut donner mais pour l'instant
il n'y a rien de concret voilà comme je
vous le dis mais vraiment rien de
concret nous on travaille sur un projet
avec marlène et j'espère que ça va
aboutir maintenant vous savez le travail
paye toujours
mais ça serait pas plus fin plus
intéressant nous avons par exemple comme
vous êtes très jeune quand vous parlez
aux jeunes sur une radio présente que
virgin alors le matinal cc guillaume
mais avec entendu parler d'un alomar là
nous je sais pas quoi mais de parler aux
jeunes et aux femmes ce que vous voulez
aussi sur une radio jeune moins bien
servis si je peux vous parler très
franchement que vous avez gentillesse de
faire tout ça un petit coaching bilan de
carrière non mais c'est gentil
j'apprécie je suis une maman avant tout
et pendant cinq ans j'ai vraiment très
peu vu mes filles et donc moi je veux
pas faire un truc qui me fasse rentrer
tard le soir ou partir le matin et que
je puisse pas mener ma fille cadette à
l'école ma priorité ce pouvoir dîner
avec mes filles le soir peut-être pas
tous les soirs mais en tout cas être là
les amener à l'école le matin peut-être
pas tous les matins mais voilà et donc
je peux pas m'engager en disant je vais
faire une matinale j'arrivais à 5 heures
où je vais faire une émission du soir je
vais rentrer à minuit voilà ma priorité
c'est méfie d'une part ce projet des ong
que je veux mener à bien et donc il me
demande beaucoup de travail si j'ai la
chance d'avoir une équipe formidable et
des gens qui me soutiennent et donc
voilà on verra rouvert à ce qui se
présentait mais bravo à ceux qui se
lèvent tôt le matin et qui se couchent
tard le soir on va bien sûr l'ancien pas
très bien avant tout camarade merci
marlène schiappa c'est une bonne
situation sa ministre très intéressant
ascione raconte
en immersion et c'est vrai qu'on apprend
énormément de tout ça va vous plaire
les shérifs